oh hello i know
right how's it going everybody it's
warren welcome back to my channel the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and today we have some
major mcu news perhaps possibly
some of the biggest news in mcu history
according to a recent report that came
out last night
now i know i don't normally do videos on
sundays but i'm doing this video on
saturday night because this
is insane news especially when it comes
to ryan reynolds and deadpool
everybody is just absolutely excited for
him to finally enter the mcu and
everybody is wondering when
and it seems like we're going to find
that out relatively soon as there has
been a report that ryan reynolds is in
talks with marvel studios right
now to sign one of the biggest deals in
marvel history
now this report is coming from daniel
richmond daniel is a community insider
in the marvel and dc
universes and a lot of his scoops in the
past have been right so he's a very
credible source
and last night on his patreon account he
posted this scoop
marvel cco kevin feige is interested in
wanting to sign deadpool star
ryan reynolds to the biggest deal in mcu
history
now this isn't said lightly this is an
extremely big deal
not only big as in the contract is big
but the impact on the mcu it could have
is insanely big as well now just to put
this in perspective for you
robert downey jr initially agreed to
four
movies three iron man movies and an
avengers movie then of course his
contract was renegotiated
multiple times and ultimately he would
end up appearing in nine
mcu films iron man iron man 2 the
avengers iron man 3
avengers age of ultron captain america
civil war
spider-man homecoming avengers infinity
war and avengers end game
so what this report is saying is that
ryan reynolds's deal with marvel studios
is going to be
bigger than robert downey jr's that
means that ryan reynolds is going to
sign up for potentially 10 or more
mcu films now of course ryan reynolds is
coming back as deadpool
everybody loves ryan reynolds deadpool i
think everybody would riot if ryan
reynolds wasn't playing deadpool anymore
and
in deadpool 2 ryan reynolds wanted full
control over deadpool so we know that he
loves the character and he wants to be
in control over it
so no doubt that ryan reynolds is going
to be playing deadpool in the mcu
however that doesn't mean that they
won't use him for other potential roles
for example he could play deadpool but
he could do the voice over for another
character but if we think about
just who deadpool is it would actually
make sense for
marvel to throw him in a bunch of
different mcu movies while giving him
his own deadpool movies at the same time
if there's anybody that can hop through
the multiverse in a very comedic fashion
it's definitely deadpool and not to
mention in the post-credits scene of
deadpool 2
ryan reynolds does get a time travel
device
now of course deadpool 2 is fox and it's
not related to the mcu
but with deadpool you can do things that
you can't normally do in other movies
and that's because
deadpool breaks the fourth wall there's
no place like home
oh and i share that home with someone
you've met the old blind lady from the
laundromat
al god i miss cocaine
her fourth wall break inside a fourth
wall break
that's like 16 walls so he can address
the fact that he used to be in another
universe but is now in the marvel
cinematic universe and he can do this in
kind of any other film that marvel wants
to throw him in
but with this insanely huge deal we can
assume that we are going to get a
deadpool 3
most likely a deadpool 4 and have him
show up in a very big movie
most likely in an avengers type film and
then most likely in an x-men film as
well
and then at the end if marvel decides to
do secret wars he'll be there as well so
that's
five movies right there and then they
can sprinkle them in the mcu and other
different movies here and there
throughout time
which is something i think nobody would
have a problem with absolutely
at all so in future videos we'll talk
more about how deadpool could be one of
the biggest characters in the mcu so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of that news
and also don't forget to subscribe so
you can enter for a chance to win a
cyclops funko pop i'm picking a winner
on monday
don't forget to like the video and you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
for live updates and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof you're still here
it's over go home